contesta mark art history Manuel
Schaefer is checking out the new XF
whose release marks Jaguars 80th
anniversary the first generation came
out in 2007 and it's been the
best-selling jag ever since the new
generation has been given a technical
and visual overhaul the British business
sedan recently appeared in German
showrooms the basic two liter 120
kilowatt a performance diesel version
has a starting price of just over 41,000
euros but we tested the largest of the
three available diesel motors the
3-liter
but I detected our car Chester says it's
225 kilowatts or 300 horsepower
predestinate for solid driving
performance the XF accelerates from 0 to
100 and just 6.2 seconds and reaches a
top speed of 250 kilometers an hour the
manufacturer rates fuel consumption at a
low five point five liters per 100
kilometers vente [ __ ] a man whoa says
the driver can choose among four
different driving modes the push of a
button a sporty dynamic normal eco to
save fuel or winter for wintry Road
conditions 525 intelligence ossified
missing it the 8-speed automatic
transmission is standard with a three
liter engine and the other models it
costs two thousand five hundred euros
extra the exterior the XF exudes
sportiness led by function xenon
headlights with intelligent high beams
cus 1550 euros
from the side the Jaguars flat
silhouette underscores its dynamism the
rear lights wrap around on the sides to
chrome-plated exhaust pipes and to the
sporty look yog Wathan our car Chester
knows that Jaguar has added an
additional 51 millimeters to the new x.x
wheelbase the backseat passengers reap
the benefit more legroom the price of
each of the XF models includes the no
worries Jaguar care package with a 3
year guarantee no matter how many
kilometers you put on it that includes
all regular inspections and a mobility
guarantee which means you receive an
alternative vehicle while your car is
being repaired
the big 8 inch in control touchscreen
functions intuitively like a smartphone
then the Hellmouth manual says the
interior fulfills the high expectations
placed on Jaguar good workmanship is
everywhere he has one knit to pick
though the high-gloss black surface
around all the buttons which highlights
every fingerprint I think the tourney to
ensuring all the new Jaguar XF underbody
is seventy-five percent aluminum this
enabled the engineers to make the car
190 kilograms lighter than its
predecessor at the same time this
increases torsional stiffness by twenty
eight percent which greatly enhances the
handling dynamics
as is customary in this class of car the
XF has a wide array of driver assistance
systems including a lane assistant a
lane departure warning adaptive cruise
control and a traffic sign recognition
system like the f-type and the XJ the
new XF is manufactured at the Jaguar
Land Rover Factory and Castle Bromwich
England
the noise to get manual concludes that
the new generation of the Jaguar XF is
an extremely well-designed car offering
little to criticize so it has the best
chances of continuing the success story
of its predecessor
when uh Toki spore introduced the Osetra
at six in 1955 industry specialists
thought it was the bee's knees the
vehicle not only had six rows of seats
but also a self-supporting body an
independent suspension which were
unusual back then it was innovative bus
design because in those days most
manufacturers built bus bodies on truck
chassis which had rigid axles the
killeen for the artist and mata scored
says that bus drivers 60 years ago
confirmed that on the road the s6 handle
like a car montes adds that compared to
a modern car it's quite different but
you really do get that impression if
you're driving a vintage car from the
same era nada says the gear shift on the
steering column take some getting used
to because you don't shift the gears the
same way it's up front down front rather
than right front right back it's a
little bit different
well he says you can hear the
transmission which is saying hello I'm
the gearbox and wanted to say hi the s6
was the smallest cetera ever built with
a capacity of 26 people including the
driver it's 66 kilowatt 1.4 liter engine
allows the bus to cruise at around 100
kilometers an hour even today coaches
aren't allowed to go faster in Germany
that day about Samantha says it can only
get up to 100 km/h and straightaways or
going downhill so prepare to take it
slow Klopas exponent but back in
nineteen fifty-five speed wasn't so
important the autobahn montes says back
then the cars didn't go much faster than
120 km/h either so the cetera s6
wouldn't have been perceived as slow but
today however he says he feels as if
he's blocking traffic still Monta says
the nice thing about driving an old bus
is that everyone looks smiles and waves
coking subang involution l is my anish
feed avec back then the lines of the s6
were state-of-the-art design these days
the buses curves are more reminiscent of
a beetle for a fish
the independent suspension was more of a
necessity than an innovation at six
meters seventy long the overhangs were
too short to work with fixed axles the
driver sits behind a bakelite steering
wheel and a clearly arranged instrument
panel unlike today the signal light
liver was located on the right next to
the gearshift passengers got to sit on
comfortable seats in standard 1950s
modern style I the type of montes finds
the s6 is panoramic windows particularly
charming he says these broad expanses of
glass are no longer possible today for
technical reasons but back then on sunny
days he says you could pull down a shade
and chill out a bit my default routine
on heads of non vision house 60 decades
of development later a bus looks like
this that says he can drive the s6 with
his driver's license but not the new S 5
11 HD it's too heavy and several
generations away from the s6 technically
he asked if they have anything at all in
common as I'm the representative
Matthias Lynn says the s6 is
self-supporting body was pioneering back
then he refers to an old photograph
showing 6 people carrying the frame and
tells mattis this construction principle
is still used in modern buses montes
asked if there's anything about the old
buses interior that is still the same
today just like the 5-11 of today the s6
was a tour bus you no longer see the
panoramic roof windows but it's seating
system was innovative the seats reclined
and if a neighbor got too close for
comfort the seat could be shifted a bit
into the aisle item to knock bong-soo
naw Kham this chingon emitted astonish
even what does it say montes notes that
the seats are a key feature for the
passengers because most of the people in
the bus use them so he's taking a closer
look at the modern model sami yes my
banawe
montes must first climb six steps to
reach the passenger compartment every
row of seats has foot rests a small back
seat pocket and a full down tray table
the seeds can easily be shifted sideways
the armrests raced and the seat back
reclined
a storage shelf or hand luggage is
located over the windows the ins 511
hd's 10.7 litre diesel straight-six
engine delivers 290 kilowatts of power
to ensure a constant cruising speed even
going uphill that's a cut above the
small inch and then the s6 but those
aren't the only important features in a
bus but this has many safety features
have been added since the s6 first hit
the road 60 years ago dim as X mission
without hiding is good talking about
yeah I said well Mateus whence list them
the bus is series produced with the ABA
to autonomous cruise control system it
keeps the bus from colliding with
vehicles in front of it and if a crash
is unavoidable it reduces the speed
ahead of the collision driver safety is
also crucially important if there's a
crash the driver is pulled back into the
interior of the bus and finally there's
annular ribbing to protect the
passengers which prevents the bus from
collapsing into the passenger
compartment if it overturns okay mister
you will even throw in philly pockets to
give you a list if in short a person
travelling in a bus today is as well
protected as they would be in a car
though causes mother says there isn't
much difference between cars and buses
each new model is more comfortable
roomier safer and more efficient better
than their predecessors in almost always
but no matter he says people still light
up when they see a vintage bus cruising
down the highway Chet's kinsey toda
after introducing its five-door model
opal is now adding a new station wagon
to its astral ina the Sportster the car
also boasts a brand-new engine the 1.6
litre cdti whisper diesel the 118
kilowatt engine already produces maximum
torque of 350 Newton meters at low revs
it's economical to needing just 4.2
liters of fuel to travel 100 kilometers
next year Nissan will introduce a new
version of the leaf the world's
best-selling electric car the new leaf
should have a 250 kilometers Ainge when
fully charged that's more than any other
electric car in its class if the
starting price of almost thirty four
thousand euros is too steep you can
lower it by five thousand euros by
agreeing to rent the battery rather than
buy it
it looks familiar from the outside but
the technology has changed a lot ch gave
their Ibiza series a makeover they've
amped up the compact cars electronics
and reworked its engine the basic
gasoline model now sports a 1-liter
3-cylinder engine the naturally
aspirated version comes with 75
horsepower while the Eco TSI turbo
alternative Bose up to 110 and Germany
prices for the Spanish car range from
11900 9220 1940 euros these Malcolm I
know Dyson offer our car tester says the
new Ibiza has a lot to offer
particularly on the inside the exterior
makeover is rather subtle but there is a
choice of colors for the decorative
strips around the grill the mirror caps
and the rims moon's father
it's what's on the inside that counts
but tastes differ so say outlets
customers make the e beats as newly
designed interior match their gusto
oh I know takes a look at the new he
beaches inside and points out some
changes its steering wheel is exactly
the same as in the big early on he
center display between the speedometer
and rev counter showing useful
information got bigger the navigation
system now also comes in 6.5 inches a
special feature drivers can connect
their smartphone to the ibiza within
seconds let them if it's the köppen
changes on the outside are less obvious
customers still love the e beaches
modern exterior design so say i only
tweaked it a little the compact car got
new headlamps with LED daytime running
lights and new 16 or 17 inch alloy
wheels with touches of color the trunk
holds 292 liters or even 938 leaders
once the seatbacks are flipped annoying
ziadi bitsa see yet product manager
torsten becker points out a function
called full link drivers can use it to
hook up their apple or android devices
to the Ibiza sounds complicated just
imagine a laptop being connected to a
projector it's the same principle and I
know English teleports yet wenzhou estes
here Optifine torsion asses smartphone
what's the weather like in Berlin is he
touching the reply it's not great today
it's raining and the lowest temperature
is 7 degrees
a brand new generation of gasoline and
diesel engines power the Ibiza our test
car is equipped with a 1.2 liter TSI
engine which consumes an average of 4.9
litres in 100 kilometers according to
see at the top speed is 184 km/h
the ibiza got a more fine-tuned steering
and softer suspension to make its
handling mimic the bigger leone's d
beats a style we drove for our test
costs fifteen thousand nine hundred
ninety euros in germany early next year
the more powerful top-of-the-range
cooper will complete the product range
it will come with a 1.8 liter 192
horsepower turbo gasoline engine
10 or even my notes verdict the beats a
makeover convinced him especially the
reworked chassis he says it's fun to
crunch the gears his tip is the one
liter version sporting three cylinders
and 110 horsepower because it has a top
speed of 200 km/h with low fuel
consumption making affordable small cars
for the common person is an Italian
specialty this tradition began in the
1930s with the first series production
compact to boast a four-cylinder engine
the Fiat 500 that are known as the top
alena our classic car expert Christophe
Bauer explains the origin of the little
mouse he says that in 1933 Fiat
patriarch Giovanni AG Nellie
commissioned a 29 year old engineer
named Don teja cosa to develop an
economical small car its selling price
was to be not more than 5,000 lira just
half that of a Fiat palmilla the
company's cheapest model at the time and
the new card needed to be more
comfortable powerful and good looking
than the competition from Germany and
France Krista feels that was a tall
order for a young engineer but when it
went into production in 1936 the Fiat
500 fulfilled all of the criteria but
one it cost 8900 lira not 5,000 still a
pretty fair price Christoph thanks
beginning in 1936 the little Fiat was
assembled on a modern production line at
the carmaker's lingotto plant in torun
by 1954 some 520,000 a B and C model
topoli nose had been built aside from
the sedan the 500 was also available as
a station wagon initially called the
Chardon era and later the belvedere but
how did the fiat 500 come to be known as
the top alino kristef says that in the
early 1930s walt disney's mickey mouse
became popular in Italy but due to
licensing issues Mickey was known here
as topolino or Mouse lino and because
the 500s free-standing headlights bear a
slight resemblance to Mickey's ears it
soon was given the nickname Copely know
the Fiat 500 proved to be robust durable
and fuel-efficient it has rear wheel
drive like most models of its day but
other than that its basic structure is
very similar to that of modern compacts
as its firebox Christo says the top
alino seats two adults comfortably with
space for luggage behind the seats
there's no trunk lid you could fit two
children and back here but Christophe
says Italians love to fill their top
Alito's up to the roof and if it had a
nice soft top like this one then even
beyond that no one cared that the
maximum payload was just 50 kilos but
then phia had sold it as a fully-fledged
card by 1938 Fiat had equipped the axles
with longer leaf springs so carrying
lots of cargo was no longer an issue the
magazine motor sport says the top alino
could travel 100 kilometers on seven and
a half liters of gas the best fuel
consumption ever seen at the time later
500b models like this one use just five
liters per 100 clicks the likely a bit
more when going uphill the fifth leading
off come let's be a cow's kids light on
Mia
as exactly when it comes to design Chris
now says the top aleena was clearly
influenced by the streamline shapes that
were popular in the 1930s even the door
handles are sunken to improve the cars
drag coefficient he knows that only when
the body is secured to the light ladder
frame does the top elite will have the
necessary stiffness it was a clever way
of reducing the cars weight which also
lowered its costs and fuel consumption
for the same reason parts of the frame
were perforated a technique that had
previously only been used in airplanes
and race cars and the car also used
these little 15-inch wheels specially
made by Pirelli which made the car look
big and dynamic this topoli no belongs
to the relatively rare b series which
was only built from nineteen forty eight
to nineteen forty nine
it's much-loved retractable textile roof
came as standard and a redesigned
dashboard pepped up the car Spartan
interior but the models most important
improvements are to be found under the
hood if yet fruitfulness hristov says
the main difference between the fiat 500
v and its predecessor is the engine
while the a used a side valve inch and
the be at overhead valves this technical
innovation gave the car a big power
boost from 13 horsepower to 16 and a
half horsepower usually the radiator is
found up here behind the engine enabling
the car to have a sleek and aerodynamic
front end and of course fee I put the
engine as far forward as possible to
create more interior space so while the
firm was bent on saving money they
didn't scrimp on technology christov
says the only drawback is the crankshaft
which only has two main bearings so
after just 50 thousand kilometers the
engine often needs and overall win but
the throaty sounding inline
four-cylinder engine has to work pretty
hard it's zero point six liters of cubic
capacity means it can reach just 95
kilometers an hour just enough for the
autostrada italian motorways but the top
alino is best for winding its way
through narrow city streets like here in
trentino I don't fight Christophe says
for people with big feet like him the
car is not so easy to drive because the
pedals are so close together but
otherwise it's great fun to drive around
with the wind in your hair and in its
day the top alino impress card testers
to one german magazine praised its low
center of gravity good weight
distribution and great road holding but
first and second gears aren't
synchronized so when downshifting you
really need to double D clutch but
Italians love to do that anyway they
call it La Pieta is always on see I can
he take the stink lungful numb not
object
top Felinos weren't just popular in
Italy they were exported around the
globe to as far away as China Australia
and the US the little Fiat was also
produced under license by NSU and
Germany steyr pork in Austria and simca
in France
his method effing Christophe says the
top alena was Italy's best selling car
until the mid-1950s some five hundred
twenty thousand were built it brought
mobility to the masses in Italy like the
VW Beetle did in Germany innocent when
2cv did in France with its lightweight
construction and quality technology it
was years ahead of the competition and
it established the fiat brand as
specialist for stylish high quality
small cars making the top alino a
milestone in automotive history
Dante giacosa he totally knows creator
worked for Fiat for almost half a
century developing dozens of other
models for the car maker Fiat later
revived the 500 name and continues to
produce 500 badge super minis to this
day
you